finally new rules since half the country
will believe an evil cartoon version of
Hillary Clinton no matter what she says
or does she has to embrace it sweet
grandma Hillary she done fine in 2008
but this year the voters are not in the
mood for steady as she goes their
pitchfork angry and they don't want
America's nicest grandma they want the
wolf with bits of grandma in its teeth
they want a ruthless mafia boss who will
protect their frightened Souls which is
why Hillary has to own all the nasty
things they haters say and run as the
notorious HRC try as I might I cannot
make my brain work like a trump voter
maybe it's my mother not drinking when
she was pregnant but
I just don't get how Trump has been able
to convince so many people that even
though he's a lying cheating conniving
scumbag that's why we should vote for
him look it's gonna use all that on our
enemies sure he's a scumbag but he's our
scumbag he brags about gaming the system
paying off lawmakers shafting workers
using bankruptcy he says nobody knows
the system better than me which is why I
alone can fix it but there is one person
who knows the system better and maybe
that's why her laugh sounds like this
so if America thinks it can only be safe
right now with a vindictive power-hungry
sociopath that could be good for Hillary
cuz that's what Republicans keep saying
she is so why not go for the best
the notorious HRC and the next time they
call her crooked Hillary she should say
damn right I am
crooked for America Hillary and then she
should end every one of her campaign ads
with on crooked Hillary and not only do
I approve this message I will cut a
[ __ ]
I mean why not for a quarter of a
century Republicans have been creating
this incredible super villain named
Hillary Clinton who is a serial killer
and a traitor a terrorist mastermind a
sex addicted lesbian and we found out
last week from dr. ben Carson oh yes he
said it a devil worshiper nobody could
accuse this Hilary of being low-energy
she's a combination of Lady Macbeth
Cruella De Vil and Glenn Close in fatal
attraction Donald Trump puts buildings
up she buries people under them you know
that they're actually used to be a
website called the Clinton body count
which ran a tally of the people that
Hillary and Bill had secretly killed it
was over 90 people she should demand it
be brought back and say stop lying about
my record I've killed way more than that
when Donald Trump gets mad at somebody
he sends out a mean-girl tweet in the
middle of the night that's cute
here's me killing bin Laden
and Gaddafi's ass is a little sore these
days too
Oh Hillary should say I can't wipe out
Isis please I will wipe them out and
make it look like a skiing accident
I'm crooked Hillary and I don't give a
[ __ ] so take a step back or you're next
my pantsuit is stitched together from
the carcasses of the multitudes I have
made disappear you want a strong man I'm
a stronger stronger strong man that
whiny little [ __ ] could ever be and to
those who accused Hillary Clinton of not
being able to work with Republicans she
should say Republican prosecutor Ken
Starr exonerated me Republican
congressman trey Gowdy of the Benghazi
committee exonerated me Republican FBI
director James Comey exonerated me
you're right I don't work with
Republicans I beat their ass at their
own game
people say lock me up fine lock me up
you think I'm scared of a stretch in the
joint I can run this [ __ ] from
the inside
El Chapo got nothing on me
Karl Rove says I have permanent brain
damage
uh-huh I do that's right I'm the crazy
guy in the subway you sure you want to
make eye contact I didn't think so oh
and one other thing Ben Carson was right
on the money when he said I pal around
with Lucifer who the hell do you think
Tim Cain
you